meine Lieben Zuschauer es ist mehr als
drei Monate her dass die viel
diskutierte und lang erwartete
ukrainische Gegenoffensive gegen die
russischen Truppen 2023 offiziell
begonnen hat seitdem weisen viele
Kritiker darauf hin dass die ukrainische
Fortschritte über einen so langen
Zeitraum hinweg nur mager sein ein
Dörfchen hier ein Städtchen dort die
extreme Langsamkeit der Ukraine die
russischen Frontlinien zu durchbrechen
hat manchmal Zweifel Fragen und
Nachrichten wie diese hervorgerufen
verte August 2023 ist die gegen
Offensive der Ukraine gescheitert Kiew
und seine Unterstützer fürchten die
Kontrolle über das Geschehen zu
verlieren
9 August 2023 eine entstocken geraten
Offensive und ein Patt im Winter hätten
besondere Auswirkungen in den USA es
könnte die Frage nach der Unterstützung
der Ukraine aufwerfen da ein schwieriges
Wahljahr bevorsteht die Gegenoffensive
ist schwierig sie läuft wahrscheinlich
langsamer ab als manche Menschen es sich
wünschen in unseren Augen ist Müdigkeit
zu sehen aber in ihren Augen ist Angst
zu sehen und das sind zwei sehr
unterschiedliche Dinge wo Leute die mir
selenski ja es ist klar dass sich die
Dinge oberflächlich betrachtet nicht
ganz so schnell entwickeln wie es sich
manche erhofft hatten trotzdem sollten
wir nicht zu schnell vor einige
Schlüssel ziehen angesichts des
Pessimismus und das allermeismus vieler
Medien und enormen Ungeduld derjenigen
die wie besessen auf Karten und
frontverläufe starren weil sie glauben
dass es in diesen Krieg nur um Gelände
Gewinne gehe könnte die reale Lage auf
dem Schlachtfeld jedoch ganz anders
aussehen ja die Russen leisten
erbitterten Widerstand aber was habt ihr
erwartet niemand in diesem Krieg
kapituliert auf Anhieb schon gar nicht
eine ar massiv vom Umfang her immer noch
riesig ist um euch eine Vorstellung
davon zu geben es wird geschätzt dass
die Russen derzeit immer noch mehr als
400.000 Soldaten in der Ukraine
stationiert haben allerdings haben wir
eine Sache hier bei visualpolitik schon
oft betont und zwar bereits vor der
Invasion ein Gebiet anzugreifen und zu
erobern ist nicht dasselbe wie es zu
verteidigen und zu halten das ist in der
Regel eine viel kostspielige Operation
oder Ball liegt jetzt eben im Feld der
Russen fakt ist die gegen Offensive
verläuft an mehreren Fronten
gleichzeitig aber besonders in der
Oblast saporea das Ziel dort die
russischen Verteidigungslinie zu
durchbrechen die zu Ehren des
abgesetzten ehemaligen Chefs der
russischen Streitkräfte in der Ukraine
auch als zorovik in Linie bekannt sind
offenbar war es das erste große Ziel
melittopol zu erreichen und dort die
russischen Verteidigungsanlagen in der
Region der ukrainischen Artillerie
auszusetzen
das ist keine leichte Aufgabe die
Wahrheit ist dass die suru vicky-linie
ihre Aufgabe durchaus erfüllt hat
nämlich den ukrainischen Vormarsch zu
verlangsamen und viel teurer zu machen
und das ist durchaus eine Entwicklung
wie wir sie vorhergesehen haben es ist
zum Beispiel denkbar dass die Ukrainer
mit ihren Leopard Panzern und ihren
westlichen Truppentransportern
versuchten könnten die russischen
Verteidigungsanlagen in der Nähe von
mellito polgard janz und sogar Mario
Porto durchbrechen anstatt sich wie
bisher auf den Don was zu konzentrieren
diese Angriff könnte also in der oblass
saporicia beginnen allerdings eben
weiter im Osten nicht in denen nach der
Sprengung des überfluteten Gebieten die
russischen zertifikationsanlagen wenn
man sie denn überhaupt so nennen kann
können also die Verluste der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte erhöhen sind
jedoch kaum dazu geeignet deren
tatsächliche Schlagkraft zu schwächen
aber natürlich behauptet niemand dass
die gegen Offensive ein Kinderspiel
werden würde und dies erklärt auch warum
die Vorbereitung so lange gedauert haben
trotzdem muss man sich im Klaren darüber
sein dass es eben an dieser Stelle für
die Ukraine besonders schwierig wird
vorzustoßen während des von 1991 der
Operation desertstorm brauchten die mir
als 1700 Kampfflugzeuge der US-geführten
koalitionsgruppen über einen Monat und
mehr als 100.000 Einsätze und knapp 300
Marschflugkörper und die irakischen
Streitkräfte so weit zu vermürden dass
die bodenkampagne eingeleitet werden
konnte mangels Luftwaffe muss die
Ukraine aber diese Lücke im offensiv
Raum durch präzisions Artillerie
Marschflugkörper und Drohnen überbrücken
erst wenn sie damit die entsprechenden
analogen Ziele erreicht hat lohnt es
sich mit der hauptstadtmacht am Boden
vorzurücken alle bisherigen Vorschüsse
der mobilen Bodentruppen hatten also nur
den Zweck den Gegner quasi aufzusuchen
um ihn in Bewegung zu versetzen
aufzuklären eine Reichweite zu bringen
und seine Versorgungslinien auszudrücken
fakt ist zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme
dieses Videos befinden sich mehr als
9/10 der ukrainischen offensiv Truppen
noch immer nicht im Freund Einsatz die
ukrainische Armeeführung wird sie erst
dann einsetzen wenn Sie sicher genug ist
dass die Lage reif ist für die nächste
Phase das wird der Fall sein wenn die
russische Artillerie Luftverteidigung
und Logistik so stark ausgedünnt sind
dass die eigenen Verluste gering sein
werden und Ende august wurden wir dann
mit Nachrichten wie diesen konfrontiert
30 August 2023 ukrainische Truppen haben
die erste der drei hauptgrabenlinie der
Russen überquert 30 August 2023
rabortina ist erste ukrainische Bresche
in russische Verteidigungslinien die
Einnahme des kleinen Dorfes wird also
wichtiger Schritt in der Gegenoffensive
gesehen die darauf abzieht die
Landbrücke zwischen Russland und der
Grimm zu kappen und damit moskauz Kräfte
in dem besetzten Gebieten im Süden zu
ersticken dabei handelt es sich um den
ersten klaren Bruch in der Frontlinie
seitdem hat die Offensive an Tempo
zugelegt und die Lücke wurde immer
größer und größer die ukrainische
Hoffnung sieht so aus dass sobald die
Hauptlinie durchbrochen ist die
russischen Verteidigungsstellungen
dahinter nicht mehr so gut vorbereitet
sind manche Quellen gehen nämlich davon
aus dass die Russen auf die ersten
Verteidigungslinien 80% ihrer Kräfte
konzentriert haben allerdings kamen zum
Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieses Videos
vermehrt Meldungen wie die folgende
17 September 2023 Sorge nach
ukrainischen Vorstoß Russland verstärkt
offenbar Verteidigungsstellungen bei
dogmak bereitet sich darauf vor zum
dreh- und Angelpunkt der zweiten
Hauptverteidigungslinie Russlands zu
werden Verbesserungen an den
Verteidigungsanlagen der Stadt sind
wahrscheinlich ein Hinweis auf die
wachsende Besorgnis Russlands über
taktische Durchbrüche der Ukraine durch
die erste Hauptverteidigungslinie weiter
nördlich dies kann natürlich als
untrügliches Zeichen dafür gewertet
werden dass die Russen die vordere
Verteidigung nun tatsächlich verloren
haben und ernsthaft befürchten müssen
dass sie Trockner verlieren könnten aber
auf die außerordentliche Bedeutung
dieses strategischen Punktes werden wir
später noch detailliert eingehen denn
trotz all dem zeigen sich viele
Analysten noch immer skeptisch die
Ukraine kann jetzt nicht gegen Russland
gewinnen aber ein Sieg bis 2025 ist
möglich rich and barrenz ehemaliger
General der britische Armee andere
Analysten darunter auch die Ukrainer
selbst weißen dagegen darauf hin dass
die gegen Offensive gerade erst begonnen
hätte diese Kampfhandlungen werden auf
die eine oder andere Art und Weise
weitergehen bei Kälte Nässe und Schlamm
ist es schwieriger zu kämpfen die Kämpfe
werden aber weitergehen die gegen
Offensive wird weitergehen kirillo budan
auf Kiews Geheimdienst-Chef die Frage
ist also wo genau stehen wir eigentlich
wie läuft die gegen Offensive was können
wir wirklich von der militärischen
makro-operation der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte erwarten stehen wir vor
einem Misserfolg einer ewigen
Ankündigung oder einem beinahe Sieg in
diesem Video werden wir natürlich all
diese wichtigen Fragen von umfänglich
beantworten lasst mich euch aber vorher
noch eine andere wichtige Frage stellen
hättet ihr Lust noch bis Ende September
einfach mal so ganz schnell 155 € von
Finanzamt einzustreichen dann guck mal
hier denn schon am 2 Oktober Ende die
steuerfrist für das Jahr 2022 und
praktischerweise wird das heutige Video
von Steuerbord gesprochen hat eine
äußerst praktischen App mit der ihrer
Steuererklärung ganz easy am Handy in
nur 20 Minuten machen können denn
wusstet ihr dass viele deutsche
Steuerzahler jedes Jahr
unglaublich viel Geld verschenken nur
weil sie von der komplexen
steuerbürokratie abgeschreckt werden
dabei würde es sich durchaus lohnen sich
mal zu überwinden schließlich haben laut
Statistischen Bundesamt im vergangenen
Jahr 12,3 Millionen Menschen eine
Steuererstattung bekommen und zwar im
Schnitt eben jene 1.95 Euro und mit
Steuerbord muss man sich noch nicht
einmal überwinden um an die
Steuererstattung zu kommen Steuerbord
ist nämlich quasi sowas wie Chichi BT
mit einem steuerberatungsplugin das
während es mit ihr plaudert im
Hintergrund schon mal deine
Steuererklärung ausfüllt und optimiert
innerhalb von 20 Minuten ist die
Steuererklärung fertig und zu
Übermittlung als Finanzamt bereit
komplett papierlos und digital und
sollte es notwendig sein unterstützt
sich auch der fachkundige menschliche
Support jederzeit mit garantierten
Antwortzeiten innerhalb von 24 Stunden
übrigens sollte die Steuererstattung
unter 50 € liegen berechnet die
Steuerbord keinerlei Gebühren und ist
dann vollkommen kostenlos also schenkt
dem Staaten nicht euer sauer verdientes
Geld und klickt auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung oder es kennt den
eingeblendeten QR-Code um bis Ende
September noch mal zusätzlich 10 €
Rabatt zu bekommen du deinem Geldbeutel
einfach mal was Gutes und von jetzt
gleich an so einfach steuern so sparen
wie nie zuvor vielleicht kommt aber ja
genug herum dass du damit auch unsere
Arbeit finanzielle unterstützen kannst
den Spenden Link dazu findest du
übrigens ebenfalls in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video so und wenn ihr dies
erledigt habt gehen wir schnell wieder
zum Thema des heutigen Videos zurück wie
wird die Gegend Offensive der Ukraine
aussehen und Ausgehen aufgepasst
künstliches Beatmungsgerät
in der Medizin wird ein schwerkranker
Mensch oft an ein Beatmungsgerät
angeschlossen werden wir eine Parallele
zu potenzielen könnten wir sagen dass
turovic ins Verteidigungslinien in der
Ukraine das künstliche Beatmungsgerät
sind das die Macht des russischen
Diktators am Leben hält der
Zusammenbruch der russischen
Verteidigung in den besetzten
ukrainischen Gebieten könnte für
Wladimir Putins macht er halt verheerend
sein und genau deshalb zieht der
russische Führer alle Register damit
dies nicht passieren Russland das eine
größere Armee anstrebte will das
Höchstalter für den Militärdienst
anheben Russland greift zu einer Reihe
von Taktiken um Männer zu überreden oder
zu zwingen sich zu Militär zu melden um
seine Verteidigung in der Ukraine zu
stärken ohne dabei auf eine
Massenmobilisierung zurückzugreifen die
politische und soziale Spannungen im
eigenen Land verursachen könnte
natürlich darf man nicht all die
psychologischen Tricks vergessen mit den
Putin versucht hat westliche Politiker
und die Öffentlichkeit einzuschüchtern
und so Spalten damit der Westen die
Ukraine nicht schnell und ausreichend
genug mit Waffen versorgt nur auf diese
Weise jemand der jene für ihn wertvolle
Zeit schinden in der seine Truppen unter
der Führung des mittlerweile
geschosssten zurowweg in diese
Verteidigungslinie überhaupt aufbauen
und fortifizieren konnten mit anderen
Worten ohne das ständige Zögern und
Zaudern von Politikern wie Scholz macron
und auch beiden wäre Putins macht heute
eventuell nicht mehr als ein Kapitel in
den Geschichtsbüchern ja natürlich hat
die Unentschlossenheit des Westens dazu
beigetragen Putins macht und damit das
Leiter Ukraine viel weiter zu verlängern
als notwendig und natürlich hat dies die
Ukraine viele zusätzliche Menschen Leben
gekostet der Punkt ist jedoch das gerade
jetzt die eben erwähnte künstliche
Beatmung Putins die Verteidigungsanlagen
zu bröckeln beginnen zumindest an
einigen wichtigen Abschnitten wie
bereits gesehen haben ist es in Ukraine
bereits gelungen die surubic inlinie um
die Stadt Roboter zu durchbrechen von
dort aus versuchen Sie nun den Riss in
Richtung zu vergrößern und nach Pokémon
vorzudringen in einem strategischen Ort
der buchstäblich von russischen
Verteidigungsanlagen umgeben ist die
Russen haben alles unternommen und
Werken als auch weiterhin tun um zu
verhindern dass trockenmarkt fällt das
liegt daran dass diese Ort ein wichtiger
Verkehrsknotenpunkt ist sowohl für
Straßen als auch für
Eisenbahnverbindungen mit anderen Worten
Tokmak ist für die Versorgung der
russischen Gruppen im Süden der Ukraine
und auch der Creme unerlässlich bevor
sie lenskys Truppen jedoch topmak
erreichen müssen natürlich noch mehrere
befestigte hintere Linien überwunden
werden daran arbeiten sie in der
Hoffnung dass diese Linien Schwäche sind
als die erste aber selbst wenn sie recht
haben und erfolgreich sind wird diese
Operation Zeit und viele opferkosten ein
zweiter ukrainischer Vorstoß findet an
der Front bei Berlin
darüber hinaus sind auch Operation
Umbach Mut im Gange zudem haben die
Ukraine vor kurzem auch eine
druckoperation auf Picknick den
Flughafen von Don jetzt gestartet aber
alle diese Vorstöße werden wir am Ende
dieses Videos zu einem Gesamtbild
zusammenführen tatsache ist dass sich
nach den Entwicklungen Ende August und
Anfang September der allgemeine Diskurs
in den Medien plötzlich sehr schnell
verändert hat 31 August 2023 ukrainische
Gegend Offensive durchbricht russische
Hauptverteidigungslinie in Südosten nach
drei Monaten mühsamer Fortschritte in
der vom Besten unterstützten Operation
beschleunigt hier den Vorstoß entlang
der hauptangrifflinie
17 September 2023 der russische
vollmarsch an der kopiensfront
verlangsamt sich was ist der Grund dafür
das hängt erstens damit zusammen dass
sie in der Nähe von novoirefka einen
schweren Schlag erlebten haben sie
gruppieren sich neu nachdem sie von den
ukrainischen Streitkräften geschlagen
wurden
Front bei bachmut Ukraine meldet durch
Brechen von russischer
Verteidigungslinie nochmals mitschreiben
das alles bedeutet nicht dass die Ziele
der Ukraine in greifbarer Nähe liegen
und der Krieg von nun an einen
Kinderspiel sein wird aber es zeigt
eines die meisten westlichen Medien und
Analysten vor allem jene die sich gern
als neutral darstellen leider nicht nur
an einem Mangel an Geduld nein sie sind
dazu auch noch generell zu pessimistisch
und haben eine recht verzehrte
Vorstellung davon wie kriege dieses Typs
verlaufen schließlich verlaufen solche
Konflikte praktisch nie linear
Verteidiger können ihre Stellungen
zunächst lange Zeit halten und dann
innerhalb weniger Tage oder Wochen
brechen sie zusammen so dass sie
gezwungen sind Kräfte von anderswo zu
mobilisieren und damit die gesamte
Verteidigung als Ganzes so Schwächen
seit dem Beginn der Gegenoffensive sind
kommt 14 Wochen vergangen und das
bedeutet aus militärischer Sicht dass
sie sich noch in einem recht frühen
Stadium befindet durch befestigte
Verteidigungsanlagen zu dringend ist
eine äußerst komplizierte und
kostspielige Aufgabe um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben dass
US-Militär diese Art von Operation in
der modernen Geschichte erst zweimal
durchgeführt und beide Male ging es
gegen den Irak 1991 hatten sie mit Hilfe
der Koalition die zur Befreiung kuwels
gebildet worden war Erfolg nachdem sie
die Iraker nur 39 Tage lang unerbittlich
aus der Luft bombardiert haben und
anschließend 650.000 Soldaten auf sie
loslassen und 2003 schafften sie es
gegen eine bereits sehr schwache
irakische Armee nur wenigen Tagen aber
auch da nur nach intensiven
Luftangriffen abgesehen davon gibt es in
der jüngeren Vergangenheit keinen
Präsident für das womit die Ukraine an
der südfrontiert sind
und der große Unterschied ist dass die
Ukraine keinen der strategischen
Vorteile hat die die USA einen beiden
Kriegen gegen den Irak hatten die
Ukraine verfügen über keine Lufthoheit
können nicht im Luftraum über den
russischen Linien operieren und können
auch nicht verhindern bei ihren
Vorstößen von russischen Flugzeugen
Hubschraubern und Drohnen angegriffen zu
werden außerdem verfügt die Ukraine
trotz umfangreicher westlicher
Waffenlieferungen noch nicht über
ausreichende Mengen angepanzerten
inklusionssystemen ja und genau aus
diesem Grund versuchen die Ukraine eben
vorsichtiger vorzugehen im Gegensatz zu
den Russen ist ihnen das Leben ihrer
Soldaten verdammt wichtig um so krasser
und zyllischer sind deswegen die
Vorwürfe aus dem Westen die Ukraine
würde nicht schnell genug vorrücken und
nicht genug Fleisch in den Fleischwolf
werfen diese sind genauso erbärmlich und
unmenschlich wie die Forderungen die
Waffenhilfe an die Ukraine einzustellen
und natürlich ist auch der feinfaktor
wichtig die Hosen verfügen nun mal über
weitaus größere und bessere ausgerüstete
Streitkräfte als zum Beispiel die Iraker
schließlich galten sie vielen Experten
die leider noch immer auch heute noch in
den Medien Gehör finden als die
zweitstärkste Armee der Welt hinter den
USA nur damit euch das damit verbundene
Ausmaß an Verantwortungslosigkeit
bewusst wird zu einem großen Teil haben
viele dieser Experten mit ihren
Einschätzungen auch in starkem Maße die
westliche Öffentlichkeit und Politik
beeinflusst damit diese dann wie gesagt
den Russen ausreichend zeitgaben um jene
Verteidigungsanlagen aus breiten
minengürteln Panzer Abwehr geben
Drachenzähne und Schützengräben auf die
besetzten Gebiete Ukraine zu errichten
und zu bemalen außerdem sind die
russischen Soldaten mittlerweile mit
viel mehr Drohnen ausgestattet die
Artillerie Angriffe steuern und die
vorschlüsse der ukrainischen Truppen
ausnutzen um einen Gegenangriff zu
starten wenn die Ukraine erschöpft oder
müde sind Stichwort Drohnen beide Seiten
haben seit Beginn des Krieges eine
massive drohnenfertigung aus dem Boden
gestampft teils in Fabriken teils in
kleinteiliger Arbeit aus dem 3D Drucker
es wird gebaut und gegen den Gegner
geschickt warst du irgendwie fliegen
kann und die Ukraine Lüften zunehmen den
Vorhang von über ihrem geheimnisvollen
Projekt namens Drohnen Armee es geht
natürlich nicht nur um drohen die die
Truppen auf dem Schlachtfeld einsetzen
sondern auch um Sedrun zum Angriff auf
russische Schiffe und die kernbrücke
sowie weit ins Russische Hinterland
reichende Kamikaze Drohnen sie alles
sind auch ein fester Bestandteil gegen
Offensive die eben viel mehr ist als ein
Bodenkrieg die ukrainischen
Drohnenangriffe üben enormen Druck auf
den russischen Generalstab und die
Kriegswirtschaft aus am Ende dieses
Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen worum
es geht ich habe es schon im ersten
Video zu Beginn der gegen Offensive
erwähnt es handelt sich um sogenanntes
shaping man formt sich nicht nur die
Frauen sondern den gesamten Gegner für
seine kommenden Operation zurecht und
tastet seine Schwachstellen ab hierzu
zählt dieser Störung von Bomben auf
Flugplätzen tief im russischen
Hinterland die Zerstörung der russischen
Luft Abwehr und Artillerie auf der Krim
und natürlich auch die Angriffe auf die
russische Schwarzenberg Flotte in
Silvester toll all diese Erfolge der
letzten Tag und Wochen demonstrieren die
Fähigkeit der ukrainische Streitkräfte
viel komplexere und
koordinationsintensivere
Informationen auszuführen als die Russen
dazu in der Lage sind der Angriff auf
silvastopol war auch eine
shading-operation und erfolgte nach
einer Reihe vorbereitender Operation zur
Schwächung der russischen Verteidigung
die es in Ukrainern dann ermöglichten
den Angriff mit einer äußerst kleinen
Zahl von Raketen und Drohnen
durchzuführen wahrlich eine Glanzstück
an militärischer Effizienz servustopol
hätte eigentlich die am besten
verteidigte russische Basis im gesamten
Kriegsgebiet sein müssen und doch haben
die Ukraine wieder einmal das scheinbar
Unmögliche geschafft ja im Grunde klingt
es fast unglaublich die Ukraine
behauptet sich doch tatsächlich ohne
eigene Marine im See Krieg gegen die
mächtige russische Schwarzmeerflotte die
eigentlich dafür sorgen sollte und
deshalb einzunehmen nun ist sogar das
Gegenteil der Fall die Ukraine ist doch
tatsächlich dabei diesen krass
asymmetrischen Seekrieg zu gewinnen die
russische maride befindet sich quasi im
deckungs- und fluchtmodus na was meint
ihr sind diese Erfolge nicht sogar noch
bemerkenswerter als die an Land schreibt
mir doch in die Kommentare was dies
ihrer Meinung nach über die Aussichten
der beiden Seiten aussagt denn während
die Ukraine offenbar in der Lage sind
strategische Erfolge auch unter nur
minimalen Kosten zu erreichen konnten
die Russen ja bisher meist nur ein
großer Überzahl und unter extremen
Verlusten Erfolge vorweisen sie sind mit
ihrer Holzhammer Methode gegen das
ukrainische Köpfchen ein Leuchtturm der
Ineffizienz also was denkt ihr kann der
Kreml mit dieser Strategie überhaupt
über kurz oder lang gewinnen oder es ist
eher wahrscheinlich dass sie irgendwann
die Puste ausgeht und das Ziel des
Pentagons der totalen Erschöpfung oder
russischen Armee erreicht ist ich meine
niemand hat behauptet dass es schnell
gehen würde und nichts kosten würde aber
es ist unter dem gegebenen und eben
beschriebenen Umständen sowohl
bewundernswert als auch unglaublich viel
sagen dass die Ukraine selbst im
Angriffsmodus erheblich geringerer
Verluste aufweisen als die russischen
Verteidiger um euch noch mal zu
verdeutlichen wieso die so kritisch ist
Putin Zukunft könnte vom Ausgang dieser
Operation abhängen und natürlich wäre
ein zusammen Bruch der russischen
Verteidigungslinien praktisch
unumkehrbar wenn die künstliche Beatmung
versagt ist der Patient nicht mehr zu
retten deswegen kann es sich der Kreml
auf keinen Fall leisten koste es was es
wollen und viele von euch fragen sich
jetzt wahrscheinlich was mit beiden
Seiten passieren könnte und was unter
den gegebenen Umständen die Stärken und
Schwächen der Ukraine und der Russen
sind und deswegen werden wir beides
jetzt ganz genau unter die Lupe nehmen
passt gut auf
am Point of no return
die Gegenoffensive befindet sich auf
ihrem Höhepunkt die von beiden Seiten
abgefeuerten munitionsmengen haben ein
Maximum erreicht und das kommt selbst an
Details zum Vorschein die nur die
wenigsten auf dem Radar haben ja meine
Lieben Zuschauer wie bereits erwähnt
wollen wir unserer und auch eurer Zeit
nicht damit verschwenden dass wir euch
in täglichen Lageberichten mit
kartenleserei ohne wirkliche
Aussagekraft und aufgebauschten
Wasserstandsmeldungen Relevanz
vorgaukeln nein all dieses Rauschen muss
man filtern um das Wesen dieses
Konflikts in seinem Kern zu verstehen
und auch sinnvoll prognostizieren zu
können wo er hinsteuert viele Fragen uns
ja regelmäßig wie konntet ihr nur
bereits 2020 einschätzen wie schwach die
russische Armee wirklich ist wie konntet
ihr schon vor der Invasion im Februar 22
voraussehen dass sie kommen wird und wie
konntet ihr nur wissen dass ich die
Ukraine erfolgreich gegen die Russen
verteidigen kann nun der Schlüssel zur
erfolgreichen Analyse liegt nun mal
nicht ein willkürlich eine große Zahl
frei zugänglicher Quellen aufzuzählen
sondern darin die Spreu vom Weizen zu
trennen das heißt die Quellen zu prüfen
und zu gewichten und dann anhand dessen
so zu einem Gesamtbild zusammenzufügen
das aus einer Fülle von Thesen und
Antithesen eine sinnvolle Synthese
entsteht aber schauen wir uns das ganze
doch mal an einem konkreten Beispiel an
Werft mal bitte einen Blick auf diese
Grafik sie zeigt die Zahl der
kriegsbedingt ausgelösten Brände in
freie Umgebung das heißt meist fällt und
Waldbrände in der Ukraine meistens sind
diese Breite durch Bombardierung
entstanden hauptsächlich also durch
Artillerie beschossen wie ihr sehen
könnt liegt die Zahl der brennende
aktuell nicht viel höher als letztes
Jahr um diese Zeit aber ganz wichtig ist
vor allem ein Detail die Gebiete die
jetzt am meisten unter diesen brennenden
leiden sind die von Russland
kontrollierten ohne wofür ist dies nun
ein klares Zeichen nun natürlich dafür
dass die Ukraine mittlerweile eine
deutliche Artillerie Überlegenheit
erlangt haben und von der russischen
Front enorme Zermürbung verursachen
wohlgemerkt die waldbahnstatistik ist
schon der zweite Indikator der unsere
These bestätigt den ersten haben wir
bereits in einem früheren Video erwähnt
die Resignation von General Popov der
die Armeeführung dafür kritisierte dass
sie nicht für ausreichendes gegen
batteriefeuer sorgen würde damit dürfte
diese Tatsache also so gut wie gesichert
gelten und das ist schon eine gewaltiger
Fortschritt denn die Überlegenheit ihrer
Artillerie war immer der wichtigste
Schlüsselfaktor der russischen Strategie
gewesen außer ihr hatten sie nie
wirklich andere richtige Asse im Ärmel
allerdings um ein wirklich schlüssiges
Analyseergebnis zu erhalten müssen wir
diese Verschiebung der Verhältnisse auch
in den passenden Kontext setzen denn
offensichtlich hat das Brechen der
russischen Artillerie Überlegenheit
nicht ausgereicht damit die Ukraine
einen blitzschnellen Durchbruch erzielen
also über welchen Kontext sprechen wir
hier nun an dieser Stelle konnte in den
Bereich der Stärken und Schwächen die
erste Stärke Russland sind dieser Phase
ist wenig über raschend dass der
Verteidiger fast immer einen Vorteil
gegenüber dem Angreifer hat dank dieser
Tatsache verfolgt Russland einen
defensiven Ansatz der als elastische
Verteidigung bekannt ist
die elastische Verteidigung besteht nach
russischer Lesart aus einer ersten Linie
von defensivtruppen die dem ersten
ukrainischen Angriff gegenüberstehen und
sich dann ins solide
Verteidigungspositionen zurückziehen
wenn die Ukraine vorrücken und wir
sprechen in der Regel von einigen
hundert Metern oder höchstens einem
Kilometer erleiden sie große Verlust
durch Minen Artillerie Hubschrauber und
Drohnenangriffe denn Panzer können nicht
durch Minenfelder vorrücken
minenräumfahrzeuge können leicht aus der
Luft bekämpft werden und Infanterie die
sie durch tragbare Flugabwehr schützen
könnte ist z.B gegenüber der Artillerie
verwundbar durch diese Kombination von
verteidigungselementen werden die
Ukraine also zermürbt und erschöpft und
genau dann versuchen die Russen in der
Regel einen Gegenangriff zu starten der
in vielen Fällen erfolgreich verläuft
und die Ukraine dazu zwingt sich dorthin
zurückzuziehen von wo aus gekommen sind
und am besten Fall auf Position die den
Vormarsch extrem verlangsamen ja das ist
pure und harte zerbürgerung durch die
russische Verteidigung aber um diese
Strategie umsetzen zu können braucht man
eine Menge Menschenmaterial
ja und genau das ist eine der Stärken
Russlands denn es verfügt über ein drei
bis viermal größeres
Mobilisierungspotenzial als die Ukraine
das liegt einfach daran dass die
Bevölkerung des putinreiches zahlenmäßig
viel größer ist und auch daran dass
viele ukrainische Männer im Kampf gegen
Alter als Flüchtlinge im Ausland leben
tatsächlich besteht praktisch die
einzige von der russischen Führung
bereits angegangen in der dritte
Priorität um die Front gegen die
ukrainische gegen Offensive aufrecht zu
erhalten genau darin dieses Potenzial zu
nutzen
[Musik]
zu diesen Zweck hat Russland ein neues
Gesetz verabschiedet das ist erlaubt
diskret ein buchungsbescheid an so viele
Männer zu verschicken wie die Regierung
will es hat das Alter für die
Wehrpflicht von 27 auf 30 Jahre
angehoben und schließt nicht aus es in
Zukunft weiter anzuheben russische
Männer die das Pech haben den
Einberufungsbefehl zu erhalten bekommen
eine elektronische Benachrichtigung und
automatisch werden die russischen
Grenzen für sie geschlossen so dass
jeder versucht das Land zu verlassen
vergebens ist außerdem wurden mit dem
neuen Gesetz auch die Strafen für die
Verweigerung des Militärdienstes erhöht
all das wird begleitet von einer wahren
Flut staatliche Gelder für die
Militärindustrie um Waffen und Munition
für all diese neuen Soldaten zu
produzieren und wie alle wisst
verhandelt Russland sogar mit Ländern
wie Nordkorea über munitionslieferungen
ja das zeigt einerseits wie verzweifelt
Putin mittlerweile sein muss dass er
sich an dieses parialand wendet
andererseits in der Zustand und vor
allem die Zahl nordkoreanische Waffen
nicht zu unterschätzen schließlich
handelt es sich um das am stärksten
militarisierte Land auf diesem Planeten
theoretisch könnten wir also davon
ausgehen dass Russland über größere
Kapazitäten verfügt als die Ukraine
sowohl um die Beteiligten Streitkräfte
zu erweitern als auch um seine Reihen zu
regenerieren außerdem scherzt sich der
kremme die ihr wisst überhaupt nicht um
menschliche Verluste was eben dazu
beiträgt die Frontlinie mit frischen
Menschenmaterial besetzt zu halten
wieder einmal zeigt sich das
Psychopathie äußerst hilfreich sein kann
um sich an der Macht zu halten und zwar
so lange bis auch das nichts mehr bringt
[Musik]
denn natürlich befinden sich die Ukraine
immer noch auf dem Vormarsch die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive bereitet
Moskau wahrlich weit mehr Kopfzerbrechen
als Freude auf strategischer Ebene
begünstigt nämlich die Geometrie des
kriegshowplatzes die Ukraine auch wenn
sie sich nicht in einer
Verteidigungsposition befindet ihr müsst
nämlich verstehen dass ich die Russen in
einer Phase befinden in der sie die
Versorgungslinie am Boden unbedingt
verteidigen müssen diese werden im
Etagen GLC genannt groundlines of
communication konkret geht es um
Versorgungslinien aus Straßen und einem
Eisenbahnnetz das von Roßdorf am Dorn in
Russland bis zur Krim verläuft über
diese Verbindungen kommen Lebensmittel
Treibstoff Munitionen Personal und alle
notwendigen Versorgungsgüter über die
Straße oder die Schiene zur Front all
das erklärt zum Beispiel warum die
Russen so verbissen pokmark und die
Brücke von Kirch befestigt haben sogar
durch keine mit unter Wasser an die
drohnennetzen und der Punkt ist nun das
ist den Ukraine gar nicht mehr vor
Wintereinbruch gelingen muss die Küste
des Asowschen Meeres zu erreichen um die
für die Russen Lebens- und
kriegswichtigen Versorgungslinien
abzuschneiden die russischen
Versorgungslinien verlaufen nämlich
nicht direkt an der Küste des Asowschen
Meers sondern viel weiter Land einwärts
die logistisch unverzichtbare Autobahn
M14 die in ost-richtung und weitgehend
parallel zur Küste verläuft ist etwa 7
bis 10 km von der Küste entfernt entlang
der Entfernung befindet sich der
breitere logistikorintor mit all den
Nachschub und munitionslagern Treibstoff
Lagern wichtigen Kommando Posten
Reserveeinheiten und Militär Bahnhöfen
die für die Versorgung der Front und
aller Verteidigungsanlagen notwendig
sind und dieser Logistik Korridor wird
buchstäblich mit jedem Zentimeter den
die Ukraine befreien enger 16 September
2023 Cluster russischer
Militärausrüstung in pogmark getroffen
sobald sich die erwähnten russischen
Einrichtungen nämlich in Reichweite der
ukrainischen Artillerie befinden steht
die russische Führung vor einer
Entscheidung zwischen Pest und Cholera
mit dem Namen den Winter wird sich die
logistische Situation der großen
westlich von mellitopol wahrscheinlich
immer weiter verschlechtern die Zeit
arbeitet also gegen die Russen nicht
gegen die Ukraine wie viele meinen und
wie im letzten Herbst am Westufer der
Putin gezwungen sein die Realität
anzuerkennen ja er kann seine Truppen
weiterkämpfen lassen und riskieren das
viele davon kapitulieren oder in
panikmodus flüchten oder er kann Ihnen
den geordneten und freiwilligen Rückzug
erlauben so oder so wird damit aber der
nächste Dominostein fallen die
Landbrücke zur Kremmen die einzige
Hoffnung der großen besteht im Moment
nur darin dass die Ukraine keine
weiterreichende Artillerie am vorderen
Rand des kampfgebiets aufstellen können
denn diese Einheiten sind extrem
wertvoll und müssen von sicheren
Positionen ausziehen bis 15 km hinter
der Frontlinie eingesetzt werden die
Zerstörung dieser russischen Hoffnung
könnte aber eben durch die Einnahme von
Roboter oder eine andere neue rote
ausgelöst werden wenn es den Ukraine
gelingt sehen die russischen
Befestigungen der Kampffront
einzudrängen und diese zu überspringen
von dort aus hätten die Ukraine dann die
gesamte Versorgung der russischen
verteidigungskapazitäten in Reichweite
ihrer Artillerie die Liebe bereits
gesehen haben mittlerweile der
russischen überlegen ist kommen diese
zwei Schlüsselfaktoren zusammen nützt
den Russen all ihre Mannstärke also
nichts mehr denn je mehr Männer eine
Seite benötigt desto mehr
versorgungskapazität benötigt sie auch
und sobald die russischen
Versorgungskapazitäten knapper werden
oder gar zusammenbrechen auch alle an
ihr hängenden Verteidigungslinien nach
nur kurzer Zeit zusammen und dann ist
natürlich wie wir euch bereits in einem
früheren Video gezeigt haben auch die
krimin in Gefahr nach dem Verlust der
Versorgung über druckmark wird die
russische Kontrolle über die Halbinsel
in wesentlichen von zwei Faktoren
abhängen nämlich der cash-brücke und dem
Marine Stützpunkt in Silverstone der
Punkt ist die Russen brauchen beide um
sicherzustellen dass Nachschub auf die
Krim gelangen kann die Brücke von catch
ist die bevorzugte Route für alle großen
Lieferungen nach Silvesterball hingehen
sowohl bei Bedarf Nachschub per Schiff
geschickt werden es dient aber auch als
Marine Stützpunkt der die cash-brücke
schützen kann und von dem aus die Russen
die ukrainischen Schiffsverkehr von
Odessa aus offensiv bedrohen können
diese beiden strategischen Punkte catch
und sebasto Paul Arbeiten symbiotisch
zusammen um den Russen die Versorgung
und Kontrolle über die Krim zu
ermöglichen sollte es der Ukraine jedoch
gelingen einen von ihnen außer Gefecht
zu setzen Gerät der andere automatisch
in große Schwierigkeiten und wie wir
vorhin gesehen haben schießen die
Ukraine nun alle drei Punkte
gleichzeitig und sebasto voll im Rahmen
von shaping-operationen sturmreif auch
hier haben Sie also alle Optionen
während die daraus sind knapp werden um
es noch mal zu verdeutlichen vielen
militärischen Strategie und Geheimdienst
Berichten zufolge ist bereits die suru
Weg in Vene absolut kriegsen
entscheidend wenn sie an irgendeinem
Punkt zusammenbricht und die Ukraine
durchbrechen könnte das russische
Militär in eine epochale Zwickmühle
geraten es wäre ein point of now return
ein Punkt von dem ist kein Zurück mehr
gibt aber das bringt uns direkt zur
ersten Frage zurück könnte es wirklich
so weit kommen ist es wirklich möglich
dass die Ukraine die russische
Verteidigung zum Kollabieren bringen nun
gewiss ist nichts in diesen Krieg aber
eine Nachricht könnte darauf hindeuten
dass diese Hoffnung durchaus berechtigt
ist sind das September 2023 bei nähert
sich Entscheidung Überlieferung von
Langstreckenraketen an die Ukraine da
habt ihr es also alles dort darauf hin
dass die USA kurz vor der Auslieferung
des lang erwarteten taktischen
Raketensystem der US Armee stehen
könnten das Ziel in einer Entfernung von
bis zu 300 km präzise angreifen kann
auch diese Entwicklung haben wir schon
vor einiger Zeit voll ausgesehen mit
dieser Raketen könnten die Ukraine ist
den Russen noch schwerer machen die
Frauen zu versorgen was die Chance
erhöht dass ein Teil von ihr
zusammenbricht bislang ist es der
Ukraine wo wir gesehen haben ja gelungen
die Stärke ihrer Kurzstrecken Artillerie
mit der russischen auszugleichen und sie
in bestimmten Bereichen sogar zu
übertreffen durch den neuen schrecklich
präzisen Langstreckenraketen den
Russland nichts mehr entgegenzusetzen
hätte würde die Verteidigung der
besetzten Gebiete noch kostspieliger
werden ein weiterer unglaublich
wichtiger Schlüsselfaktor wird also die
Fähigkeit des Westens sein den Ukrainern
weiterhin moderne Waffen zu liefern im
Moment sind die Abrahams Panzer bereits
auf dem Weg und weitere könnten bald
eintreffen außerordentlich gut bewährt
haben sich auch die deutschen Leopard 2
Panzer viele Beobachter haben sich ja
durch die aufgebauschte Bilder von
zerstörten oder Immobilien Leopard 2
gleich zu Beginn dagegen Offensive
blenden und so viel Schlüssel verleiten
lassen
es kam dabei sogar unter professionellen
Analysten Gerüchte auf bis zu 1/5 der
bereitgestellten Waffen darunter auch
moderne westliche Fahrzeuge wären
bereits beschädigt oder zerstört worden
doch das war wie wir bereits in unserem
früheren Videos gewann hatten pure
Manipulation fakt ist nämlich in den
ersten 14 Wochen der gegen Offensive an
der südostfront hat die ukrainische
Armee 5 der 71 ihr zur Verfügung
stehenden Leopard 2 Nutzer und
widerruflich verloren weitere zehn
Panzer wurden beschädigt aber dank ihrer
ausgeklügelten Konstruktion können sie
sehr leicht repariert und wieder im
Kampf eingesetzt werden sie wurden denn
auch umgehend zu Reparatur nach Polen
und Deutschland geschickt denn dank des
modularen Aufbaus ist Ihre Reparatur
auch weitaus einfacher als bei den
panzermodellen sowjetischer Bauart in
der Tat gestalten sich die meisten
Reparaturen dank der strukturellen
robuster des Leopard 2 sehr schnell so
dass eine umgehende Rückkehr in den
Fronteinsatz kein Problem darstellt
[Applaus]
laut dem Kommandeur des Bundeswehr
Panzer lehrbataillons 93 sebastian
wolbol ist diese auch dafür
verantwortlich dass es unter dem
Besatzungsmitgliedern Leopard 2 A6
bisher so keinem einzigen Todesfall
gekommen ist und das ist besonders
wichtig denn ein Waffensystem kann man
reparieren oder ersetzen aber ein
Menschenleben nicht dies ist eine der
Grundregeln die die Ukraine im Gegensatz
zu den Russen kapiert haben und die
ihnen wohl auch den entscheidenden
Vorteil verleiht in diesem Krieg zwei
Kulturen ja Zivilisationen diese
wirklich grundlegend auseinandergehenden
Philosophien über den Wert eines
Menschenlebens fangen bereits im
Konstruktionsbüro an denn während die
russischen Konstrukteure die Munition
direkt unter dem Geschützturm lagern so
dass diese beiden Treffer von oben
sofort explodiert und den
panzermannschaften keine
Überlebenschance bietet integrierten die
deutschen Hersteller krausmacher Wegmann
und Rheinmetall spezielle Platten in
ihre Leopard 2 um die 120 mm Munition
aufzunehmen diese Platten sind so
konzipiert dass sie bei einem Treffer
vom Panzer wegfliegen und die Besatzung
nicht verletzen und ja auch hier zeigt
sich See nicht so leugnen der Tatsache
dass durch die Lieferung westlicher
Waffen wirklich leben von Ukrainern
gerettet werden und ja ganz ähnlich wird
dies auch mit der zukünftigen Lieferung
von F16 Kampfflugzeugen sein die nicht
nur für den Angriff auf Bodenziele gut
geeignet sind sondern auch zum Abfangen
russischer Lenkflugkörper und Drohnen
mit denen der kremme die Ukraine ständig
terrorisiert und auch das Vorankommen
ihrer truppenbehindert mit anderen
Worten anders als viele Pessimisten
vorhersagen könnte die ukrainische
Kampagne mittelfristig sogar noch weiter
Anfahrt gewinnen aber so weit müssen wir
gar nicht gehen die gegen Offensive 2023
wird vielleicht ihre ehrgeizigsten
Maximalziele nicht erreichen aber wie
gesagt ungeduld ist im Krieg ein
schlechter Ratgeber es war von
vornherein klar dass die einst als
zweitstärkste der Welt geltende Armee
einer ehemaligen Supermarkt mit einer
140 Millionen großen seit 20 Jahren von
einem Diktator auf Nationalismus
Imperialismus und Militarismus getrunken
Bevölkerung nicht allein durch das
erdrückende Gewicht ihrer Stumpfheit und
überhe blichkeit kollabieren wird nein
hierzu muss die Ukraine kämpfen und der
Westen muss sie unterstützen
[Applaus]
um es noch einmal in aller Deutlichkeit
zu sagen Putin konnte diesen brutalen
Krieg nur deswegen entfachen weil
einfach zu viele westliche
Entscheidungsträger nicht wahrhaben
wollten wer er wirklich war zu welchem
Zweck er das russische Volk mit all der
Hasspropaganda durchdrängt in Westen von
seinen Rohstoffen abhängig und seine
Armee reformiert hatte es war einfach
viel bequemer diese bitteren Wahrheiten
auszublenden und weiterhin fein
Geschäfte mit seinem mafia-star zu
machen erst kürzlich hat eine russische
general wieder von sich hören lassen die
Ukraine sei ja nur der Auftakt zur
Eroberung Europas diese Art von
Drohungen dürfen keineswegs unterschätzt
werden und wir müssten ihm eigentlich
alle dankbar dafür sein und ins
Gedächtnis zu rufen wie wichtig der
Widerstandskampf der Ukraine gegen die
russischen unterdrückungspläne für alle
Europäer ist aber schaut euch doch noch
mal das folgende Video an
schauen
in diesem rekrutierungsverbespot der
russischen Armee unterhalten sich
russische Soldaten über Immobilien in
der Ukraine der eine will eine Wohnung
im Kiefer Nobelviertel patchers sobald
es erobert ist der andere sagt er
bevorzuge und deshalb weil er eine
Schwäche fürs Meer habe tja so sieht es
aus die Propaganda ist flächenmäßig
größten Landes der Erde pusht allen
Ernstes eine perverse Lebensraum im
Westen und ködert Rekruten mit
versprechen über reiche Beute
unglaublich es führt uns aber vor Augen
dass Russland wohl Niro geben wird bis
es nicht der restlos besiegt seine von
Putin vergiftete Volksseele nicht vom
Hass auf alles was westlich von ihm
liegt gereinigt worden ist doch können
wir von einem dreimal kleineren Land das
seine Armee erst von 9 Jahren quasi auf
der grünen Wiese aufbauen musste
verlangen diese Herkules Aufgabe für
Europa vollständig zu übernehmen und die
russische Gefahr sofort und restlos zu
eliminieren nein so wie Putin die
Grundlagen für den Krieg über viele das
scheibchenweise gelegt hat müssen sie
auch wieder abgetragen werden 2022 wurde
die russische Panzerwaffe gebrochen 2023
die Artillerie Überlegenheit und 2024
wird wohl das Jahr der Luft
Überlegenheit
anders und schneller geht es
bedauerlicherweise nicht denn zu mehr
haben die Europäer leider keine Eier und
die Ukrainer keine Mittel und ja ich
weiß dass viele Menschen in Europa der
Gedanke an einem derart langen Krieg
betrübt oder nervt zynischerweise auch
wenn sie gar nicht dem Schrecken des
Krieges direkt ausgesetzt sind aber
leider ist Weltpolitik eben kein
Wunschkonzert und in Russland ist der
wiederbele gegen den Krieg minimal es
scheint eine der traurigen Wahrheiten
dieser Zeit zu sein dass erst wenn auch
alle Bewohner Moskau und St petersburgs
den Terror des Krieges auf eigene Haut
zu spüren bekommen langsam mit einer
Erläuterung und katarsis zu rechnen ist
und erst dann mit dem endgültigen
Untergang der russischen Militär macht
Europa auch wirklich dauerhaften Frieden
hoffen um es noch mal klarzustellen
diese Feststellung hat nichts mit Hass
auf Russen oder Russland zu tun und
allen die uns so genannte russophobie
vorwerfen kann ich nur folgendes
entgegnen wer dazu aufruft Russlands
illegalen Krieg und völkermörderische
Besatzung als ernsthafte Alternative zum
Widerstand der Ukraine und ihrer vollen
Unterstützung zu akzeptieren ist ein
Helfers Helfer der kremmelmafia die
Erfolg dazu aufgewickelt hat über ein
anderes Herz zu fallen es unterwerfen
und womöglich auszulöschen und wem
Russland und die Russen wirklich am
Herzen liegen weiß dass die krämmelmafia
verlieren muss damit auch das russische
Volk wieder Frieden und Freiheit finden
kann die Grundvoraussetzungen dafür ist
eben dass die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnt
ja in diesem Sinne läuft die gegen
Offensive nicht nur jetzt nicht
annähernd so schlecht wie viele
behaupten nein sie lief nie schlecht
diejenigen die dies behaupteten oder gar
jetzt noch behaupten haben wie gesagt
das Wesen dieses Krieges nicht wirklich
begriffen dieser Krieg ist ein
anpassungswettlauf ein Marathon keine
Sprint oder drei Tage fällt zu wie in
sich Putin vorgestellt hat wer hier
ständig vom glotzen auf Karten und
frontverläufe besessen ist und Erfolg
oder Misserfolge in Boden gewinnen müsst
beweist damit nur dass er nichts von
diesem Konflikt verstanden hat nicht nur
weil er dann sprichwörtlich den Wald vor
lauter Bäumen nicht erkennt sondern auch
weil es eben nicht darum geht Boden zu
gewinnen sondern darum den Feind zu
besiegen klar auf den ersten Blick mögen
diese beiden Dinge gleichbedeutend
aussehen aber der Unterschied ist
gewaltig es ist quasi der Unterschied
zwischen der Einnahme bachmuts und Talk
Maxx die Eroberung war Mut hat Russland
strategisch rein gar nichts gebracht im
Gegenteil es handelte sich um eine
honigfalle der Ukraine und nun wissen
die Russen überhaupt nicht was sie mit
der unter riesigen Verlusten eroberten
aber Hypnosen Position anfangen sollen
hierzu stehen in krassen Kontrast die
wertvollen ukrainischen Fortschritte der
letzten Wochen sie haben dazu geführt
dass die ukrainische Streitkräfte die
Verteidigungslinie der Russen
durchbrochen haben um die ersten
befestigten Linien zu erreichen und
diese dann auch durchbrechen zu können
wohlgemerkt die wichtigsten
Verteidigungslinien lagen in
Wirklichkeit schon davor Panzer
abwehreinheiten schwerer Panzerfahrzeuge
und dichtbemannte Schützengräben jetzt
drängen die Ukraine seitlich vor um die
freundlichen westlichen östlich der
beiden hauptangriffspunkte an der SAP
Frauen zu der stabilisieren was den
Druck auf die russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen noch weiter
erhöhen wird gleichzeitig hat es die
Ukraine jedoch auch geschafft sich an
der bachmut Front wieder das Hochland zu
sichern und auch dort die wichtigste
verteidigungslieder der Russen
durchbrochen die Ukraine haben nun eine
Möglichkeit entweder nach Osten auf die
zweite Verteidigungslinie vorzustoßen
und so die Bedrohung für die
besasserbach zu erhöhen oder Sie können
resetten mobilisieren und einem breitere
Offensive starten oder den Großteil
ihrer Streitkräfte woanders hinverlagern
und die Bemühungen verstärkten die
russische Verteidigung im Norden oder
noch festen der Stadt zu durchbrechen
aber wie auch immer Sie sich
letztendlich entscheiden wie so oft hat
die Führung der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte bewiesen dass sie der
russischen einen Nasenlänge voraus ist
wenn es darum geht Optionen für sich zu
schaffen und den Gegner gleichzeitig
alternative Optionen super rauben denn
darum geht es schließlich selbst immer
mehr Optionen zu haben während den
anderen immer weniger zur Verfügung
stehen auf diese Weise müssen die Russen
nämlich viel mehr ihre Kräfte binden um
für die Abwehr jedes dieser möglichen
Szenarien bereit zu sein genau dazu
dienen auch die Vorstöße der Ukraine bei
obdünne um Performance und wurde da
es kommt jetzt genauso wie wir es zu
Beginn der Gegenoffensive vorausgesagt
hatten auch wenn wir dafür damals und in
den Wochen danach als nicht neutral
genug kritisiert wurden in anbetrachter
komplexen russischen
verteidigungsstrukturen bestehend aus
Minenfeldern Schützengräben und der
anfänglichen Artillerie Überlegenheit
schien es zweifelhaft dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte ein Durchbruch
erzielen könnten ohne den russischen
Verteidiger an einen erheblichen
Abnutzungskampf zu liefern schon damals
haben wir aber prognostiziert dass die
ukrainische Strategie vor allem die
Artillerie Überlegenheit brechen wird
durch gezielte Schläge gegen Waffenlager
Munition und führungszentren der
russischen Truppen an der Front mittels
Artillerie Drohnen und Marschflugkörpern
ebenso wurden und werden noch immer
russische Nachschublinien gestört
wodurch wichtige Verbindungsbrücken und
Bahnhöfe zerstört werden selbst wenn
Punkte von Kim mehr Artillerie Munition
bekommen sollte wie soll er sie jetzt
noch an die Front bringen Russland ist
unausweichlich in die strategische Falle
der Ukraine gelaufen und wohlgemerkt es
ist schon die dickste Falle in die der
4D schachmeisterstratege put schön
getappt ist ganz anders die Ukraine denn
anstatt brachial mit dem Kopf gegen die
Wand vorzugehen binden und strecken sie
durch ihre Taktiken die russischen
Streitkräfte um anschließend
zielgerichtet in die entstandenen
Schwachstellen einzutringen so muss die
russische Militärführung ständig mit dem
Durchbruch mehrerer ukrainischer
Brigaden rechnen von denen auch jetzt
noch etliche nicht aktiv in
frontgeschehen sind und auf den
geeigneten Moment warten für Russland
verursacht die Verteidigung der
besetzten Gebiete deswegen ständige
Unsicherheit und erheblichen
logistischen und auch mentalen Stress
der russische Vorstoß auf kopiens war
noch mal so etwas wie Hitlers
sprichwörtliche Angriff Steiners mit dem
alles in Ordnung kommen sollte aber im
Unterschied zu Hitler hatte Putin hier
mehrere 10.000 Soldaten massiert um die
Verbände der Ukraine von ihren offensiv
Operation abzulenken nach dem Fehlschlag
dieses Angriffs und den Front Einbruch
beim für Russland so symbolträchtigen
bachmut wird deutlich das Moskau seine
Handlungsfähigkeit eingebüßt und
wirklich die Initiative verloren hat es
sich immer mehr in der defensiven
Position wieder kann nur reagieren und
hat Schwierigkeiten die Frontlinie
adäquat zu sichern während die Ukraine
noch über ausreichend Reserven verfügt
hinzu kommen wie erwähnt die großen
Unterschiede bei der Effizienz und bei
den Verlusten ja diese multifonten gegen
Offensive ist eine Sisyphusarbeit für
beide Seiten die russische Armee steht
vor der ständigen Herausforderung
Reserven zu verlegen und nachzuziehen
und potenzielle Schwachstellen
abzusichern doch genau das war wie wir
bereits in unseren Videos vor zwei und
drei Monaten erklärt haben die Intention
der Ukraine und sie waren besser darauf
vorbereitet die von Ihnen eingesetzten
Einheiten sind nach wie vor vollständig
besetzt und fit während der Russen immer
mehr Lücken sowohl bei der personellen
als auch bei der materialausstattung
aufweisen dieser Trend ist eindeutig und
wohl auch nicht mehr umkehrbar auch der
Einbruch der schlammzeit und des Winters
wird daran nicht viel ändern klar die
ausgeklügelte ukrainische Strategie hat
einige der Listen die ihre tiefe und ihr
eigentliches Wesen nicht erfassen
konnten in die Ehre geführt und dazu
verleitet sie als gescheiter zu
betrachten und leider verwechselten auch
einige unserer Zuschauer
Ergebnisoffenheit zu Beginn einer
Analyse mit einer diffusen Neutralität
ihrer Ergebnisse bulgo sich ja nicht
festlegen zu wollen natürlich eine
wirklich differenzierte strategisch
Analyse basiert zwar auf ergebnisoffenen
Ausgangsbedingungen zeichnen sich jedoch
eben dadurch aus dass sie Faktoren
qualifiziert gewichtet und auf dieser
Grundlage dann auch konkrete
Einschätzungen trifft wenn einige dann
das Label Neutralität vermissen unserer
Einschätzungen als parteiischempfinden
und als Meinung zu der familienversuchen
ist das aber deren Problem denn auch
hier sehen wir wieder das ist nicht die
vermeintlich neutralen sind die immer
richtig liegen also noch mal uns geht es
hier nicht um unsere Meinung sondern um
unsere konkrete und fundierte
Einschätzung aber klar zu der muss man
halt nicht nur den Krebs sondern auch
die Eier haben und wer angesichts dieser
Situation immer noch glaubt die
Offensive der Ukraine würde nicht
erfolgreich verlaufen sollte einfach mal
ein paar Worte mit den Menschen in der
Ukraine selbst wechseln
viele Ukrainer sind mittlerweile nämlich
sehr optimistisch und auf jeden Fall
viel optimistischer als noch vor Beginn
der gegen Offensive natürlich mit den
Wintereinbruch kann sich alles
verlangsamen aber auch das wäre nichts
Neues und auch die rasputney zwar die
berüchtigte schlammzeit würde kein
großes Hindernis für die Strategie zur
Zerschlagung der russischen
versorgungsliegenden darstellen denn
dieser Fahrzeuge sowieso keine tragende
Rolle spielen es sind infanteriel
Artillerie beide mit starker
Unterstützung durch Drohnen die hier die
Hauptkräfte darstellen ja und nicht zu
vergessen die Langstrecken Artillerie
aber das ist schon wieder ein Thema von
eigenes Video vergesst also bitte nicht
das Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen falls
Sie es nicht verpassen wollt und wenn
ihr das erledigt habt seid ihr erstmal
wieder mit eurer Meinung an der Reihe
glaubt ihr dass die Ukraine die Ziele
der gegen Offensive erreichen wird wird
Russland in der Lage sein seine
Verteidigungslinien zu halten wird
Putins Regime in der Lage sein die
inneren Druck standzuhalten den eine
weitere massive Mobilisierung der
russischen Bevölkerung mit sich bringen
könnte wie immer sind wir auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt es bitte ein Like heißt mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert ist auch mit
ihnen natürlich wollen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]